[Music]
rebecca is with us in atlanta hi rebecca
welcome to the ramsay show
hey dave and christy it's an honor to
speak for you both thank you for taking
my call sure what's going on well i
first have to tell you we do dave ramsey
so much in this house that my
eight-year-old son got a splinter pulled
out this past weekend and he yelled i'm
glitter-free
that's awesome
that is so cool my whole family had a
good laugh
oh my question it is kind of similar
it's kind of similar i mean there's a
little pain involved in the extraction
but when it's out it feels better yeah
yeah yes very true
um we are on the last debt snowball it's
our um it's our vehicle and we have
gotten the payoff letter for it and my
question is my company awarded me 300
shares of an equity award in stock
and when we found you and got that
gazelle intensity going we said okay
we've learned that it's time to let this
go and cash it in
and i guess my more concentrated
question is when do we sell that because
we've been watching the stock prices
and uh the loan on the vehicle is about
a little over 29 000 if we let the stock
price go up to about 310 it covers the
whole shebang if we sell it today
we come out of pocket about 6 500 to pay
off this car
uh
well here's the principle
and the principle is is that i don't buy
stock
and the increase in value of the stock
gets you out of debt i've never told
somebody to go buy stock and
as the stock goes up it'll get you out
of debt
you didn't do that but it ends up
putting you in exactly the same place
so
if i woke up in your shoes i would sell
it today
okay because there is no guarantee it's
going up
and the principles get out of debt as
fast as possible regardless of of what
the variables that play are yeah so i i
don't buy stock and wait on it to go up
to get you out of that that's not it's
not a method that we use but but speak
to the principle here not just the not
just the idea of stock but let's dave
i'd love for you to talk a little bit
about the idea of waiting
for some potential change that would
then would able me to get out of debt
like sometimes we'll get this call of
well i don't want to pay off my student
loans because the government might bail
me out
and the principle that's at play there
is the the problem the thought process
the the idea behind that of waiting for
someone else that may or may not help me
in putting your eggs in that basket and
how dangerous that is it's almost
putting what psychologists call the
locus of control yeah outside of
yourself yeah you're saying i'm waiting
on something else to fix this where it
is my job yeah now she's not really
trying no no no but it made me think of
that it is that kind of locus of control
question though of um there's something
that happens rebecca and all the rest of
us too uh you know there's something
that happens inside of us
so powerful when we decide
deep down
deep down in the old gut
that
i'm the problem i'm the solution
i'm gonna take action i'm gonna fix this
i'm in control of my destiny none of us
are naive enough to think we're 100 in
control of our destiny but when you say
the only way this gets fixed if i
freaking fix it yeah this this being my
life yeah the only way my life gets
fixed is for me to take the bull by the
proverbial horns
and just go we are going to do this i'm
going to impose my will
just sheer action
a whole series of actions and not all of
them
necessarily
have to make perfect mathematical sense
the the value of taking action
supersedes the value of the math game
yes and i think that's it i think that's
the thing that so many people miss
because whether it's a scenario like
this one or a scenario like that i'm not
going to pay off my student loans
because of xyz what it does is it gives
us some kind of shallow justification
for not doing anything right now well i
gotta wait because this this might
happen i gotta wait and what's
interesting is then the underlying
effect is we feel like victims well i
mean the stock hasn't gone up or well
the government hasn't bailed out no no
we're telling you regardless of what
anyone else is doing you're going to
control what you can control and you're
going to get out of debt as fast as you
can become a force of nature and knock a
bunch of crap down
and if you go out there and just become
a whirling derby you become a a
tasmanian devil and you're just like
you know and you know and you know
you don't have time and you don't even
stop to think about something like she's
talking about and again rebecca's asking
a valid question totally not a shallow
question it's a valid question but the
problem is the math of what we just told
her to do doesn't work yes assuming that
stock goes up and bails her out
she have to do it she could have waited
she might have waited six weeks and the
whole thing would have taken care of
itself and yet we're telling her take
you know six thousand dollars but we
don't know what six thousand dollars is
going to happen with a single stock in a
company it is not predictable well and
there's these things out there called
pandemics and crap you know you cannot
predict what's gonna happen and so what
you can predict is what you can do and
when you start just throwing stuff and
trashing and just just tearing up just
causing a holy ruckus in your life stuff
starts getting out of your way yeah
because it's stuff i mean
things get scared they're like that
one's coming through yes i ain't getting
in the way and it's like you create this
movement in the spirit you create this
movement in your life
that that that supersedes mathematics
yeah it's just momentum is what it is
where the freedom that you're going to
experience and the control that you're
going to maintain is worth more to you
than this potential gain of six thousand
dollars in the scenario or whatever it
is in some other scenario it's just it's
the freedom and the control that you
have control over your destiny you have
control over your outcome the time in
which you become debt free and so on
that has a value to it that often we
dismiss
in the name of waiting for the
mathematics but but that's why i think
it's so important to explain this
because if you're going to tell someone
to do something that that someone's
going to you know someone's going to be
tweeting you right how am i on the math
if you do that listen if you did the
math we wouldn't be getting ourself in
this situation to begin with i think i
think explanation is needed and for
people to get the why behind the
principle of you taking control right
now today we don't love rudy or rocky
because they
had oh because they had it all figured
out and their technique was perfect we
loved them because their heart was so
big and they busted up into impossible
possible odds with a sheer force of
nature and took it down and that's why
we all stand up and cheer at those
movies
and that's what i'm asking you to become
is that person it changes everything